this is the me 20 FSH or as we've been
calling it the me 20 fish it may just
look like a black box but inside this
thing is beast like the kind of beast
that goes to 4.6 million ISO what does
that even mean basically this thing can
see in the dark with your naked eye or
iPhone can't see this Canon Canon says
it's thanks to its huge pixels two to
three times the size of most other
sensors that means that each pixel sucks
in more light so it can see things with
just point zero zero zero five Lux
that's less light than a single Firefly
emits so I put it up against the best
low-light camera currently on the market
the a7s2 turns out the a7 s puts out
less noise early on but the me twenty
fish holds up better in higher ISO
levels also the me twenty fish has some
great tools that other cameras don't
there's an IR cut filter allowing you to
capture extra infrared detail in the
dark but make sure you turn off in a day
time there are two built-in neutral
density filters so you can stop down the
light to the right exposure and there's
also a two x and a 4 x teleconverter
there's also this crazy optional remote
you can use to really fine-tune your
image on the fly and while it shines
that night it also records beautiful
images during the day
the camera itself is just a sensor in a
box
there's no viewfinder no battery plate
no XLR inputs or even an internal
recorder that means you have to fork out
additional money on top of the $20,000
already for just the body and thanks to
those huge pixels tenon can only pack
enough for 1080p on a full-frame sensor
Canon built this camera to do everything
but at its price is probably something
you're more likely to rent to get that
crazy drone shot in moonlight or to film
the magical scene with underwater
fireflies or if you're crazy director
insists on shooting by candlelight only